I’ve spent about a week with the new Apple
Watch Series 5, and yes, the always-on display
is basically the only real-world difference
I’ve noticed, which is definitely a little
disappointing, but I’ve realized that it
actually adds a whole lot more to the Apple
Watch than people think.
This is the same exact reason why we saw a
BUNCH of people comment that they’re finally
upgrading to the Series 5 from their older
Apple Watch like the Series 1, 2 or 3.
I’ll explain this reason in a moment but
first, I want to get a few things out of the
way.
If you’re currently using the Series 4,
I don’t think it’s worth upgrading to
the Series 5, unless the always-on display
is very, VERY important to you.
And EVEN then… it makes a whole lot more
sense financially to persevere for another
year with the Series 4.
But what if you have an older model, or maybe
you’ve never owned an Apple Watch and you’re
finally considering the Series 5?
Well, you chose the perfect time because I
honestly believe that for the first time ever,
the overall smartwatch package of the Apple
Watch is finally complete with the Series
5, and that’s why we’re seeing so many
people upgrade.
The always-on display was the last piece of
the puzzle, which was my biggest complaint
about the Apple Watch.
Apple not only added this feature, but they
flawlessly executed it, with new display technology
that allows the refresh rate to dynamically
lower down to just 1 frame a second instead
of the regular 60hz.
However, I have a MAJOR complaint about the
always-on display, which I’ll get to in
a minute.
Last year’s Series 4 brought some major
improvements to the Apple Watch, which help
the Series 5 be so far ahead of any other
smartwatch on the market.
The most important changes were the new S4
processor, which helped the UI become super
smooth and lag-free, alongside the new larger
curved display that is just so much better
than before, a completely redesigned sensor
housing with new updated sensors, a louder
speaker, Bluetooth 5, the ECG sensor, and
now with the new model, a large 32GB of storage.
This goes to show that the Series 5 now packs
basically all of the hardware you could ever
ask for in a smartwatch, alongside some awesome
software improvements with watchOS 6, and
people are starting to realize it.
There were quite a few users of older Apple
Watch models who were waiting for the perfect
time to upgrade, and this is it.
And now, let me explain what disappoints me
about the new always-on display.
Yes, Apple did execute the feature very well
by dimming each and every watch face in its
own unique way to help achieve the same 18
hours of battery life while still allowing
you to see some important info on your watch,
but I have one complaint about it.
I charge my Apple Watch every single night,
and I usually have about 40% battery life
at the end of the day, so I’m a bit disappointed
that Apple doesn’t let you customize the
always-on display to make it just a bit brighter
or maybe even keep the solid colors of the
watch faces instead of switching them to black.
This would definitely use more battery life,
but I’d rather lose some efficiency and
end up having closer to 10% battery life at
the end of the day instead of having the always-on
display be so grey and dim, but let me know
if you'd like to have this option down in
the comments below.
And there’s one thing missing that I think
would make a world of difference for many
people, including myself, and that’s a Watch
Face store.
Apple does have some pretty cool new watch
faces with watchOS 6, like the California,
Meridian, and Gradient, but I would gladly
paying $10-15 for a customized great-looking
watch face created by a skilled developer.
This way, developers would be encouraged to
create the best Watch Faces imaginable so
they could pull in some extra revenue, and
of course, Apple would take a cut of the sales.
That’s a win for Apple, a win for developers,
and a win for us consumers.
But as far as the Apple Watch Series 5, there’s
never been a better time to buy or upgrade.
The battery life is great, the display is
bright, sharp, and now always-on, and its
jam-packed full of all of the features most
people need in their daily lives.
If you enjoyed this review, click that circle
above to subscribe for more videos like this
one, and click right over there to check out
our detailed 1 week review of the iPhone 11
Pro that took 3 full days of work to complete.
Thanks for watching, and we’ll see you in
the next one!